now we'll hear from our 34th and current
attorney general of nevada
aaron ford
hello everybody i'm aaron ford your
attorney general
and welcome to recovery advocacy day i
wish that i could be with you in person
today but
hopefully we'll be able to meet in
person again soon
the pandemic has been hard on all of us
and stressors caused by covert 19
like isolation on those in recovery does
not go unnoticed
one of my priorities since taking office
has been criminal justice reform
specifically as it relates to behavioral
health and substance use disorder
i advocate for policies and legislation
that support these areas
last month my office settled our first
nevada only opioids settlement
with consultant mckenzie and company for
45 million dollars
based on mckenzie's role in the opioid
crisis as attorney general
i promised to go hard on those
contributing to this crisis
and i hope this settlement really sets a
precedent for all those involved in
contributing to the distress
of this crisis assembly bill 374
will create a working group that will
advise on how this settlement funding
will be allocated
throughout nevada it will address use of
this funding for prevention
treatment and recovery and i'm proud
that my office can further
existing efforts to help those in need i
want to thank each of you here today for
your passionate efforts
and your involvement with recovery
advocacy day your work
makes all the difference in the lives of
nevadans thank you